le 737 max c'est la série qui doit
assurer l'avenir de boeing
la version améliorée du 737 l'appareil
le plus vendu de l'histoire c'est le
dernier né du géant américain boeing en
a fait la publicité avec des décollages
à la verticale spectaculaire est le tout
premier appareil a été livré au
printemps 2017 au groupe lyonnais mais
dix-huit mois plus tard l'un des 737 max
8 de la compagnie s'abîme en mer de java
13 minutes après son décollage
189 personnes à bord aucun survivant
dans leur rapport les autorités assurent
que l'avion n'aurait jamais dû décoller
lors du vol précédent des capteurs
envoyer des informations erronées sur la
vitesse et l'altitude
le rapport complet sur l'écrasement du
vol 610 de la lie en air est attendue
cette année mais les boîtes noires ont
déjà indiqué que les pilotes ont tenté
une vingtaine de fois de contrer
l'ordinateur de bord finalement l'avion
a plongé à plus de 600 kilomètres à
l'heure pour l'instant boeing a reçu
5000 commandes pour le 737 max 8 soit
cette année de production assurée mais
dimanche
moins de cinq mois après le premier
écrasement l'avion ont tangué la queue
de l'appareil était en feu ils ont
essayé de relever le nez mais il a piqué
vers le sol
18 canadiens figurent parmi les 157
morts mais pas question ici
d'immobiliser les quelque 40 appareils
des compagnies canadiennes
si j'avais avalé quelque part
aujourd'hui sur un avion de ce type je
le ferai mais il y avait au moins une
inquiétude palpable
celle du marché avec une chute brutale
du cours de l'action boeing
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal